president Trump announces plans to
deport millions of illegal aliens as
soon as next week does he have the
political cojones to follow through we
will see as Alexandria cassia Cortez
compares illegal immigration to the
Holocaust a new poll shows she is
immensely unpopular in her own district
we'll see how those numbers hold up
finally the Washington Post examines the
real reason that white America turned on
Oh Jay Simpson spoiler alert it's
because he murdered his ex-wife and her
friend all that and more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
I know sometimes when it's a slow news
cycle these Washington Post writers need
to try to rehash old think pieces but
when you are scratching the bottom of
the barrel of why did white America turn
on Oh J you have really run out of
things to say I think look I don't know
I'm not sure of many things in this
world but I'm pretty sure why white
America black America all of America
turned on OJ Simpson and it's because he
murdered his wife we'll get to the big
political news today but first let me
tell you why I look and feel so good
every day I've got a spring in my step I
am hopping around so joyfully and the
reason for that is purple mattress
purple mattress you know how much I
don't need to tell you again it is the
greatest bed I have ever slept on a kid
you know I wake up in the morning and I
just lie there and I'm scrolling through
the news reading all the newspapers I
don't get out of my bed in the morning
for probably half an hour because I love
my purple so much it feels like no other
bed you've ever slept on it's not like
an innerspring it's not like a memory
foam it's this new technology that is
firm and soft at the same time how is
that possible
just try it I don't know how to explain
it to you it sleeps cool which is very
important in the summer so you don't
wake up all sweaty you know for me I'm a
Sicilian descent I'm a little bit of an
oily fella and so it's very nice to be
able to sleep cool at night it's an
amazing bed it is so great I recommend
it to all of my friends and I can't ever
foresee sleeping in another bed this is
and I love dinner Springs I was a big
fan of those this is way way better a
hundred night risk-free trial if you're
not fully satisfied return your mattress
for a full refund backed by a 10-year
warranty free shipping and returns free
in-home set up an old mattress removal
you will love purple right now my
listeners get a free purple pillow with
the purchase of a mattress and these are
nice pillows that's in addition to great
free gifts they're offering site-wide
check the way to get this is to text
Noel's Cantor wles to eight four eight
eight eight the only way to get this
free pillow is to text Noel's Cantor
wles
to eight four eight eight eight KO wles
to eight four eight eight eight message
and data rates may apply
president Trump big announcement today
he said that he is going to deport
millions of people this is the tweet
next week ice will begin the process of
removing the millions of illegal aliens
who have illicitly found their way into
the United States they will be removed
as fast as they come in this is a bold
claim
we have probably at least 11 million
illegal aliens in the country some
estimates put that number higher could
be 12 million 13 million even higher
than that President Trump says starting
as soon as next week he's going to just
deport millions of people that's his
word millions now it's a little
confusing in the way he says it he says
on the one hand we're gonna remove
millions of illegal aliens who have come
into this country illegally on the other
hand he says they will be removed as
fast as they come in so is he only gonna
is gonna be removing the ones that come
in we're getting three thousand a legal
aliens a day coming in or is he gonna
remove the 11 million that we already
have here or is he gonna do both
hopefully he's doing both but but I mean
it can't it can't simultaneously be both
right he can't remove them as fast as
they come in and remove the 11 million
that we've got if you know other it's
sort of like when you've when you're
trying to pay down principle right you
can either if you have a loan or
something you can either service the
loan and pay the the fees on the loan or
you can pay down the actual principle
that you owe if you if you're only
deporting in the numbers as people come
into the country you're not actually
dealing with the 11 million that you
already have there the other question is
can he actually do it how is he supposed
to deport 11 million people I have a lot
of sympathy for President Trump here
because he said he was going to deport
all of these people and then he gets
into office and he hasn't been
successful at that how's he supposed to
do it how do you get rid of 11 million
people in a country I mean in a country
of 300 million people that's actually a
significant portion of people how is he
supposed to do it and then there's the
political question which is do Americans
even want mass deportation maybe they
talk a good game maybe they elect a
president who says he's going to deport
11 million people do they actually want
it do they actually want to see people
being carted out of their houses you
know everyone everyone wants to deport
the illegal alien in the other town
nobody wants to deport the
illegal alien that you know that you're
friends with nobody wants to deport the
guy doing your lawn or the guy or the
lady taking care of your kids right it's
sort of the same thing with Congress
everyone hates Congress but they tend to
like their own congressmen so they say
go throw all the bums out except for my
congressman and then nobody gets thrown
out of Congress so I'm a little
skeptical will analyze the political
implications of that that this
announcement itself from President Trump
came just hours after the State
Department announced that the US was
going to be cutting aid to the biggest
offender countries for sending illegal
aliens to the United States so three
countries in Central America are going
to see their aid cut earlier it was
announced that there would be a six
hundred fifteen million dollar cut in
aid to Guatemala Honduras and El
Salvador significant money for basically
failed States they've now eased that so
now they've walked that back to about
four hundred and thirty two million
dollars again this is not I think some
of trumps critics are going to try to
portray this as a weakening or walking
it back but president Trump has bragged
for thirty years about how he always
starts out asking for 99% and he's
willing to settle for 50 he just starts
out at some outrageous number and then
he walks it back so that I think is
perfectly in keeping and we've seen
already with the trade deal in Mexico
that Trump has been pretty successful at
getting concessions out of the people
who were sending illegal aliens to this
country so I hope hope that works I mean
that's all good news however I just
can't get too excited about this
President Trump says we're gonna do it
we're finally going to get serious about
illegal immigration seems to me I've
heard that song before me president
Trump has a major credibility problem on
his hands and I say this as someone who
really wants him to be successful he has
got to deliver on the immigration
promises he's got to do it I mean he's
got to do it because it was a central
pillar of his campaign he's got to do it
if he wants re-election President Trump
can honestly say right now that he has
fulfilled more promises than any
president in Reese
history if not ever I mean that he has
been very good at fulfilling promises
great economy record low joblessness
he's renegotiated trade deals people
said he wouldn't be able to do that he's
gotten concessions out of our trading
partners
he's got relative peace abroad he ran as
an anti-war candidate there have been
moments when he could have intervened in
Venezuela or Iran right now or other
places and he has consistently refused
to do that
he's managed a very dangerous situation
in North Korea pretty well he's we moved
our embassy in Israel to Jerusalem this
has been a policy priority of the United
States for multiple administration's
he's the first one to actually do it
he's the first one to fulfill that
promise he has given us some good judges
and justices apparently originalist
justices the jury is still out a little
bit on Kavanaugh but Gorsuch seems quite
good he's given us a lot of other great
federal judges I mean he's done a lot I
don't mean to belittle what he's
actually accomplished but a central
feature of his 2016 campaign was dealing
with illegal immigration that may have
been the central feature either jobs or
or illegal immigration and he hasn't
succeeded there he hasn't gotten illegal
immigration under control we have 3,000
people a day coming into this country
illegally now what what Trump can say to
that is right there coming into this
country illegally because the economy is
doing so well they weren't coming under
into this country and those numbers
under Obama because the Obama economy
was terrible right that's true I guess
on the question of immigration Trump is
a victim of his own economic success
you've got to account for that I mean if
you're campaigning on a money
I'm gonna fix the economy the economy is
going to go gangbusters we're gonna have
record low joblessness and we're gonna
take care of illegal immigration then
you've obviously got a factor in the
economy - your immigration promises so
the economy is going great you've got
all of these economic migrants who are
pretending to be asylum seekers flooding
into this country you've got to deal
with that and I actually think he can do
it I'm not passive
about this I think he can deal with
illegal immigration I don't think he's
going to deport 11 million illegal
aliens next week but he can do it he
made a great first step with that Mexico
trade deal everyone said there's no way
you're gonna get concessions out of
Mexico there's no way that terror
threats are gonna work tariffs are
always a terrible idea tariffs have no
credibility tariffs will never work
guess what they did and Mexico agreed to
multiple concessions as well as
deploying 6000 National Guard troops to
their southern border to deal with
illegal immigration they also agreed in
that deal to keep asylum seekers on
their side of the border rather than
having them come into the United States
to just pal around here and run away
from the judge and never be seen or
heard from again
that was a good first step but 3,000
illegal aliens a day we don't have very
much wall built we were supposed to get
a big beautiful wall we don't have one
yet we don't have any real solution in
sight let's say we get 500 miles of
border wall this year that would be
great is that what we were promised for
the first term of the Trump
administration not quite he's got to
start deporting illegal aliens but this
is going to be a political nightmare
because I'm pretty certain that no one
actually wants to see mass deportation
we all think we do we all want to fix
the illegal immigration problem we don't
want there to be illegal aliens in the
country we don't want illegal aliens to
keep coming into the country but we
don't want to see mass deportation we
don't want to see it in practice because
it's ugly the problem of illegal
immigration is ugly it brings crime it
brings drugs
it creates whole hosts of problems for
the government for taxpayers for social
services for our culture because people
aren't assimilating they're not learning
English they're not coming into the
culture we are for some reason
assimilating to illegal aliens that the
encouragement of the cultural left and
the Democratic Party I mean the problem
of illegal immigration is very ugly as
well and an ugly problem is going to
require an ugly solution and and I don't
think we have the political stamina for
that so how can Trump do it one way
probably the only way is to focus on
criminal aliens
I guess all of them are criminals rather
quite literally criminals they broke the
law to come here but the ones who have
the face tattoos the ones who are in
gangs the ones committing violence rape
murder burglary
like really bad hombres to use the
president's term those are the ones
you've got to focus on and you can focus
on them as a matter of policy but even
more importantly than the matter of
policy those are the ones you've got to
focus on as a matter of messaging and
this is why President Trump needs a
really really good press secretary I say
in a leading way I ask no no there's no
I mean to take take that how you will
I'm not so Jeff could if you got like a
alright young maybe twenty nine-year-old
italian-looking I don't know I'm he
needs a good press secretary is what I'm
saying it's sort of a shame that Sarah
Sanders is leaving right now because she
is a tremendously talented press
secretary if President Trump actually
implements this policy of significantly
ramping up deportations you need a press
secretary who's able to go out there
every single day and say look at this
face look at this criminal with face
tattoos who's got blood in his teeth
who's you know chewing on human flesh
who's just like the worst guy that
you've ever seen you've got to make that
the face of illegal immigration here's
what the left is gonna do what the left
is already doing is making some little
child in a cage the face of illegal
immigration never mind that the photos
of children in cages come from 2014 they
come from the Obama administration
doesn't matter this is not actually
about the policies the left doesn't care
about the children in cages or whatever
happened if they cared they would have
raised a ruckus about it during the
Obama administration what this is about
is the issue of illegal immigration the
left once open borders they want to
flood this country with people who will
or more likely to support them
politically into over successive
generations or all but certain to
support them politically this is just
what the data and the statistics show
they want to do that they want to
radically change American culture they
want to fundamentally transform the
country as Barack Obama said and what
the right wants to do is maintain the
integrity of our nation and say a nation
has borders in a nation has laws and we
should enforce
our laws because that's how we govern
ourselves through our democratically
elected representatives that's that's
the debate that's happening now and in
the way that debate is going to be waged
is a picture of a little kid in a cage
and a picture of some face tattooed
scary wacko rapist murderer gangster
that is going to be the battle President
Trump has got to focus on that there
were two schools of thought on why
Donald Trump won one school says he won
only because of attitude not because of
policy one school of thought says he won
despite his attitude despite his
personality flaws because specifically
of his policy and only one of those
views is correct we'll explain which in
a second but first it's 2019 and
everybody needs a great pair of wireless
earbuds I love this new sponsor because
this new sponsor has the solution for
wireless earbuds before you go and drop
hundreds of dollars on a pair that are
very very overpriced I think you know
what I'm talking about you need to go
check out the wireless earbuds from Ray
Khan ray con earbuds start at about half
the price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market and they sound
just as amazing this is the problem with
wireless earbuds is you have the really
cheapo awful ones that don't have any
battery and they break in two seconds
and then you have the very high-end ones
that are extraordinarily overpriced and
there's but never been anything in the
middle that gives you that same great
quality for a more reasonable price now
ray con does that company was co-founded
by Ray J and celebrities like Brandi and
jr. Smith you know I'm listening to them
all the time
they already those those celebrities are
already obsessed Randy and Jerry Smith
they love it ray cons
e50 wireless earbuds have totally
changed the game for me I mean they are
super comfortable more comfortable than
a lot of others they're very easy to
take anywhere unlike some other wireless
options ray con earbuds are both stylish
and discreet so they're not dangling
with stems or wires they look really
cool and they don't just look right they
sound great too I love them I'm now
giving them at his gifts you should get
them to go to buy rake on Comm slash
anoles KO wles to get 20% off your order
right
that is by Ray Khan bu y ra y Co n comm
/ Knowles get 20% off ray con wireless
earbuds if you've been eyeing a pair now
is the time to get an amazing deal that
you are not gonna get a better deal than
20% off this is the best deal they're
offering one more time Rekha by Ray Khan
calm / Knowles sir there are two schools
of thought on President Trump the one
school of thought is policy doesn't
matter his voters don't care about
policy they just like that he's tough
and he talks mean and he's cruel and he
you know he's just got that look to him
the other school of thought is yeah
maybe people get a kick out of Trump's
personality he's a good showman but
actually they don't care about that they
care that he's offering a different set
of policies and a different set of
experiences than other politicians have
in the past so all of the all of the
elite kind of conservative types the
establishment types cuz the conservative
capital C trademark over the if those
guys all say that it's because of
Trump's flaws that people like him
because he's cruel because he's mean
because he's crass that's what they like
about Ann Coulter wrote an entire book
about how that is not true and actually
the reason people like him is because he
unlike every other candidate in on the
Republican side in 2016
offered different policy solutions he
didn't just regurgitate the same talking
points from 1983 he said no we actually
have to look at the effect of
globalization on the American worker we
actually have to look at our trade
policies we have to look at if we're
surrendering national sovereignty to
these massive international super
national organizations and trade unions
we need to re-examine that because we
have different problems in 2019 we need
to look at immigration
you know the Chamber of Commerce Wall
Street Journal establishment Republican
idea of unfettered open borders and
immigration that isn't helping America
that is actually hurting America and
we're gonna change that and I think
that's what people resonated with you
know the elite people tell me and look I
I aspire to be an elite person I love
luxurious things I
a smoking jacket when I go in the
backstage show but the people who are
the self-styled elites the ones who
consider themselves better than the rest
of America I think a lot of them look
down on the motivations that that cause
some people to vote for Trump they say
oh yeah they they voted for Trump
because they want revenge they want to
get back at people they're really angry
that's it's irrational it's emotional I
don't think that's it the people that I
talked to who voted for Trump more often
than not tell me they like Trump in
spite of certain personality flaws they
wish he didn't say this all the time
they wish he wasn't tweeting like this
all the time they just like what he does
and they like what he says that he will
do and that's perfectly reasonable the
question is can he do what he says he's
gonna do on this central campaign issue
I really hope he can I mean I think the
guy is a brilliant politician
I think he's got brilliant political
chops he's been very effective and I
think he fears and knows that if he
doesn't get serious on immigration he's
not gonna win in 2020 is there enough
time I don't know I'm not so sure about
that we'll have to see if Trump can
harness this massive Leviathan the ship
of the United States federal government
and use it to actually fulfill that
promise of deportations and getting
serious on the border because time is
running out about a year and a hat less
than a year and a half away from the
2020 election and by the way the left is
going to be keeping up very hard on this
issue they're gonna be going at this
issue incredibly hard as well the future
of the Democrat Party Alexandria Casio
Cortez so dubbed by the chairman of the
Democrat Party Tom Perez she has come
out and compared the Trump
administration's current immigration
policy to the Holocaust here is the poor
benighted congresswoman from New York's
14th congressional district the United
States is running concentration camps on
our southern border
and that is exactly what they are they
are concentration camps and if that
doesn't bother you
I don't I like we can have okay whatever
I'm gonna talk to the people that are
concerned enough with humanity to say
that we should not that never again
means something she's so articulate
there I have so many points to begin
with uh first of all I wanted to give
her the benefit of the doubt because one
one thing she is saying now she's saying
people are saying I'm comparing the
illegal immigration centers to the
Holocaust I'm not there's a difference
between a concentration camp and a death
camp and with these concentration camps
are where they hold people against their
will and death camps are what you saw in
the Holocaust and I was not invoking the
Holocaust and I tried to give her the
benefit of the doubt but I can't because
she specifically invoked the Holocaust
there at the end she made a specific
reference she said we're talking about
never again
if never again means something never
again is a phrase that refers explicitly
directly to the Holocaust so she is
drawing that comparison to the Holocaust
and obviously there's no comparison
whatsoever okay I'll get to the point
she's trying to make in a second and why
it's completely wrong but I want to
point something out she's obviously very
inarticulate she doesn't know how to
complete a sentence she doesn't know how
to complete a train of thought she
doesn't know how to make an argument she
says if you disagree with me then I I
can't even I don't know and then she
goes on to something else and people
make fun of her for this and they say
that it shows that she's not very
intelligent and probably that's true but
she's mastered this craft she's mastered
the art of speaking in this way because
if she were at a podium giving that
speech she would look like a complete
idiot I mean she wouldn't even be able
to fool her own base so how does she
give this speech she does it from her
couch wearing her pajamas
with blankets all around her on
Instagram sitting in Indian position
with her legs crossed and it's so casual
that she can get away with speaking
casually the trouble for AOC is she's
not capable of speaking in an elevated
way or an articulate way or in any sort
of soaring rhetoric she can't do that
that's why she does these Instagram
things because she's very good at this
we all speak casually when we speak to
each other at a bar or something we
start a sentence and then before well
actually we'll talk about this and then
we move on here and we use words
flippantly and we use lower baser
language and when we're giving a speech
giving the State of the Union we give
more elevated language even on this this
kind of medium when we're talking about
podcasts podcasts are a very
conversational medium the way you talk
in a podcast or a podcast interview is
totally different than the way you would
speak if you were testifying before
Congress or if you were at your
confirmation hearings for the Supreme
Court even that you adjust for the
medium and I think people have focused
on a OC using Instagram and Twitter
because she's young she's hip she's with
the youth I don't think that's quite it
I mean I guess she is she is young the
reason she does it is because that's the
only level of discourse that she's
capable of and so rather than try to
elevate herself and be something that
she's going to fail at she brings all of
the media that she uses down to her
level which is very conversational and
immature and childish you remember one
of her first major interviews was with
Margaret Hoover on the new version of
firing line and it was where she said ha
ha I'm not the expert I don't know and
she looked like a total fool and people
made fun of her for it and then Allie
Stuckey did that video where she
parodied the interview that was because
AOC was trying to do a more serious
long-form interview she can't do it so
now she focuses all of her attention on
social media small casual because it
excuses the way that she speaks and even
if she says something crazy like
compares u.s. immigration policy to the
Holocaust even if she does that
she's not really held to account for it
because you know it's just the way you
talk in your living room you know
sometimes people say things that aren't
true or that they come off wrong so I
actually think that strategy is pretty
brilliant especially for someone who is
as intellectually and rhetorically
limited as aoc the future of the
Democrat Party now as for what she's
actually saying she's comparing illegal
immigration centers to Japanese
internment camps first of all they're
not being held at a Japanese internment
camp not really what she's implying is
that we've got these concentration camps
that are being used for illegal aliens
actually they're being held at an army
base they're being held at Fort Sill in
Oklahoma this is not some specific
concentration camp built for illegal
aliens this is already an army base it
was used during the Second World War to
intern japanese-americans why are the
illegal aliens going to Oklahoma they're
headed there because we can't keep all
of them at the southern border you've
got these these are an illegal aliens
that have lived in the country for 20
years these are people who are currently
poring over right now since Donald Trump
was elected and we can't keep them all
in Arizona and Texas in California it's
totally unfair to those border towns in
those border states illegal immigration
is a federal problem it's a national
problem
they're not entering because they just
happen to love California they're
entering to get into the United States
because to be an American citizen or to
have a family member who's an American
citizen is the greatest political
privilege that the world has ever known
so illegal immigration is a federal
problem we already know that that's why
we have federal agencies to deal with it
and so they're finding a federal
solution and spreading out some of the
illegal aliens throughout the country
including now in Oklahoma rather than to
just a handful of border states now this
army base was used by FDR to in turn
japanese-americans not illegal alien
Japanese people but actual Japanese
Americans and the Japanese Americans
were Americans let's see what aoc thinks
about that and our values this is a
crisis for ourselves
this is a crisis on if America will
remain America in its actual principles
and values or if we are losing into an
authoritarian and fascist presidency she
contradicts herself and no one's called
her out for contradicting herself she
obviously is completely unaware that she
contradicts herself she says that these
concentration camps which by which he
really means just centers where you're
holding illegal aliens are fascist here
she is I don't use those words to just
throw bombs I used that word because
that is what an administration that
creates concentration camps is a
presidency that creates concentration
camps is fascist it's fascist okay a
presidency that uses concentration camps
is fascist so let's just follow that
logic she's calling FDR a fascist
because Trump is holding illegal aliens
in the same place that FDR held
japanese-americans and that place is a
concentration camp
according to AOC so presidents that do
this are fascists
so FDR is a fascist so ALC probably
hates FDR right isn't that right I want
in the 2020 candidate I want a 2020
candidate that says we can do these
things we can be audacious I think we
need in order to overcome this moment we
need to return to our FDR roots as a
party that's what I believe so FDR is a
fascist and I don't use that word
lightly he's really really a fascist
because of all the fascist things he did
and therefore we need to return to our
FDR policies and Donald Trump is just
like FDR so I guess AOC is now endorsing
FDR or Donald Trump rather and FDR
something like that all right today oh
so you just endorsed Donald Trump I
don't think so she has no coherence to
her thought now I'm starting to talk
like her she has no coherence to her
thought she's not following ideas to
their logical conclusion
she's just saying slogans and this is
what leftist politics have devolved down
to and new polls are showing this is not
looking very good for her we will
analyze them in a second but first I
have got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube before that I've got great news
we are taking our backstage live show on
the road August 21st to tear the terrace
theater in Long Beach California that is
right ben shapiro daily wire god-king
Jeremy boring the Andrew Klavan Lord of
the multiverse and little ol me will be
live on stage discussing the winners and
losers of politics and pop culture and
doing our best to answer your burning
questions from the audience
tickets go on sale to the public this
Friday but only daily wire subscribers
get presale tickets s today it's
happening right now it'll be on sale
today through Thursday special access
for subscribers so subscribe right now
get your tickets today and come join us
for a fantastic event it is gonna be a
ton of fun go over to daily wire calm
you know all the great stuff you get
we'll be right back with a lot more
so obviously the the AOC idea here that
these are concentration camps on the
order of Japanese internment or the
Holocaust is ridiculous the way you know
it's ridiculous is they keep coming in
3,000 of them a day 3,000 Jews a day
weren't pouring into Nazi Germany 3,000
Japanese people a day weren't applying
to become American citizens so that they
could go to concentration camps
but people are pouring into this country
every day because they're obviously not
concentration camps and I'm the question
of concentration camps
what does aoc suggest we do I mean I'm
assuming she would call the prisons that
you can hold illegal aliens and
concentration camps I'm assuming she
would call the HHS facilities where
younger illegal aliens are receiving
care should call them concentration
camps she's using that phrase to
convince you that anything other than
blanket amnesty and open borders is
wicked it's evil it's like the Holocaust
what does aoc think should happen to
illegal aliens who come here if you come
into this country illegally and you
break the law and you shouldn't be here
the federal government has to do
something with you but she's saying it's
immoral to deport people she's saying
it's immoral and Nazi asked to hold
people in custody the only other option
is to let them come in and have no
consequences and so we have no
immigration law the voters who voted in
representatives to give them certain
immigration laws they can be damned the
people who have established this rule of
law in the country they can be damned
the people who waited in line from other
countries not just El Salvador and
Guatemala and Honduras but from
countries in Africa or East Asia or
South Asia those people they can be
damned doesn't matter they don't they
don't matter at all all that matters is
flooding the country with a very
specific group of illegal aliens whose
children are more likely to vote for
Democrats that's what a or C is saying
and if you disagree with that you're a
Nazi and obviously this is horrific ly
offensive to descendants of Hitler's
victims and victims of the Holocaust
it's it's
horrific ly offensive to half of AO C's
countrymen but she doesn't care there's
no coherence if you you know as we just
did if you follow her ideas to their
logical conclusion they don't make any
sense but that doesn't matter if she can
whip up a fury and envy a mass hatred
and disdain for from one half the
country to the other half of the country
she has achieved her goal this might
backfire
a new poll suggests people are sick of
her there's a poll in her districts New
York's 14th congressional district shows
her favorability rating is down to 21%
just one in five people view her
favorably her unfavorable rating is up
to 51% 11% of people in the district
according to this poll believe she has
their best interests in mind only 13%
according to this poll would vote to
re-elect her and 33% are committed to
voting against her in 2020 so that's the
bad news for aoc the good news for AOC
is I don't buy this survey at all this
is a door-to-door survey of registered
voters conducted by a group called stop
the aoc PAC which I I admire their goals
but I just don't buy it first of all
door-to-door survey is pretty weak
it's obviously a group that despises her
and would benefit from this kind of
negative information being put out about
her very often people use polls not to
report what people are thinking not to
report on public opinion but to shape
public opinion they're called push polls
you're pushing people to or encouraging
people in the wording of the questions
to voice a certain opinion then you're
using that opinion broadly to influence
the broader public's opinion according
to a more legitimate or more credible
poll from April the Siena polling a OCS
favorables are not twenty one percent or
fifty two percent compared to thirty
three percent unfavorable 61 percent of
Democrats are willing to support her in
2020 this is already after the Amazon
decision so the least popular thing that
she did which was chasing Amazon and
25,000 high paying jobs out of her
district and around her district that's
already
factored into that siena poll from April
do we really think that in two months
her numbers have just completely
cratered by more than 50 percent I don't
think so
New York's professional 14th
congressional district is
extraordinarily Democrat it's a d-plus
29 district it has six Democrats for
every one Republican the only time in
the last century that it went Republican
was in 1946 probably she's safe on the
right probably I don't know I mean she's
uniquely unpopular and she's made
herself uniquely a national figure so
maybe some Republican campaign could
could do something who knows Never Say
Never in politics she's also very
vulnerable from the left if a Democrat
wanted to primary her I think that
Democrat would be very successful so
that's a poll that I think is not very
credible and probably doesn't matter now
let's turn to a poll that I think is
more credible and does matter I'm very
skeptical of presidential polls this far
out specifically national polls however
the state polls are a lot better because
they're more specific they've more of a
bearing on the actual presidential
election presidents aren't elected by a
popular vote no matter how much Hillary
Clinton is in a straitjacket in the
woods of Chappaqua seems to insist that
they are the presidential elections are
decided by States by the Electoral
College a new poll out spells a lot of
trouble for Joe Biden this is a
firehouse optimist poll shows Donald
Trump is surging in Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin battleground states and
cutting into Biden's lead in Michigan
there's a statistical dead heat in
Michigan so Biden had an eight-point
lead in March in Pennsylvania now that
has dropped to just a one-point lead so
statistically a tie Biden had a 12-point
lead in March in Wisconsin that has
dropped down to a six point lead so he's
still got a lead but not by a lot he's
what lost 50% of that lead and in March
Trump and Biden were tied in in Michigan
and now they are statistically still
tied the poll puts Biden up at three
points but statistically speaking
there's really little difference now I
don't care about this poll for the Jen
election that we are so far away from
the general election by own thing these
polls really matter now what this does
matter for is the Democrat primary
because of Joe Biden's only claim to
getting that nomination is that he can
beat Donald Trump in Michigan
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin that's the
only reason that Democrat voters have to
nominate him he is old he is white he is
male he is relatively moderate in a
leftist party
he is a gaffe prone he is a two-time
loser he is an admitted plagiarist he's
an admitted liar a frequent liar and
he's a creepy Harrison infer there is no
reason for Democrats to nominate
yesterday's news or 30 years agos news
the guy's been in office for like 50
years
what has he accomplished very little the
one thing he's accomplished was the 1994
crime bill and the Democrats absolutely
hate that
so why nominate him they can nominate
him because he can beat Donald Trump
except if he can't beat Donald Trump
there's no reason he's already slipping
he's already slipping before the first
Democrat debate that's really bad news
and Joe should be very very worried
right now
we should also all of us be worried
because OJ Simpson is loose the juice is
loose and he is taking Twitter by storm
Oh Jay has got some scores to settle and
here is how he describes it hello to
where the world this is at yours truly
you know this is my first venture into
the social media world and it's amazing
you know how quickly they could put up
counterfeit sites anyway we'll deal with
that we'll deal with that the hell's
that supposed to mean
when OJ Simpson says we'll deal with
something that's that's very scary he's
very upset because and obviously
whenever anybody goes on Twitter there
are like a million fake Twitter accounts
that pop up so some of them are very
charming I don't know if you've been
following me or the other daily wire
guys on Twitter but there's a Twitter
account for my pet goldfish there's a
Twitter account I think for my glasses
I'd saw one for my contact lenses I saw
they just like all of these go on and on
there's one for Jeremy borings verified
checkmark that he doesn't have there's
one for Drew's beard I mean there's one
for Benjy Amica just all of these like
fun sites so for OJ obviously
immediately they were just like OJ
Simpson's knife killer OJ all these OJ
things and allegedly we don't know for
sure one of these accounts is claiming
that OJ Simpson is sending in
threatening messages on Twitter DMS here
is one of those accounts killer OJ
reading what he says are private
messages from the real OJ Simpson
account and he shows it on the screen
within a day or two of OJ getting on
Twitter so a JD missed me again okay
look at take this up it's his actual
account I'm gonna click it here in a
minute and show you guys he continues
with the other DM he goes think I'm
playing mother and I go Sally nope look
if you're look look if my little Twitter
account with 300 followers bugs use that
much then
Manny weakest okay so I only get 301
followers it dudes trippin senior seen
that video he just posted about me think
I'm playing tired of all your bullsh I
will find your ass and cut you don't
believe me just watch and see and I go
dude there are other there are others
that literally literally have more
followers than me and more convincing
than mine left myself you gonna you're
gonna cut me awesome is that what you
said that Nicole and I guess that made
him going up enraged with all the knife
emojis he goes you next he's sending all
these threatening tweets I mean he AJ
did say in a video there were these fake
sites and we're going to take care of
them so I wouldn't be surprised at all
OJ's a complete maniac who murdered his
wife and her friend the reason this
matters is not because he's a complete
wacko maniac murderer though that I mean
I guess that's important to the story
it's because the mainstream media
specifically the Washington Post are
trying to draw some
Rann racial lesson about America's
racism out of our rejection of OJ
Simpson just to just to remind you just
to catch you up in case you missed AJ
the first time around he got off in the
criminal trial he was acquitted he lost
in the civil trial so in the civil trial
they found him guilty of the deaths of
Ron Goldman and Nicole Brown his ex-wife
why did he get off in the criminal trial
it's because of race relations in 1994
it's because at that time and don't take
my word for it a former OJ juror Carrie
best says the reason Oh Jay got off is
because in 1992 a black man named Rodney
King was beaten by the LAPD and the cops
who beat him got acquitted and this was
racial payback for that that's what the
former OJ juror said that's how it was
covered at the time he lost the civil
trial in 1997 because he obviously
murdered his wife and her friend and
again don't take my word for it he
actually admitted this in 2006 he wrote
a book called if I did it in which he
discusses how he hypothetically would
have killed his wife and her friend and
then he did an interview on Fox which
never aired because there was a lot of
blowback and and they thought it would
be too hot to air for viewers but it
finally leaked last year in which Jose
admits what he did here he is and this
guy kind of got into a karate thing and
I said well you think you can kick my
and I remember I grabbed the knife I do
remember that portion taking the knife
from Charlie and to be honest after that
I don't remember you except I'm standing
there and it's all kind of stuff around
and
what kind of stuff but and stuff around
okay so he's a complete wacko
remorseless psychopath murderer right
obviously he said he's actually admitted
what is the washington post draw from
this lesson this is the headline they
ran a guy named Philip Cunningham quote
25 years ago Oh Jay Simpson showed white
Americans just how conditional their
comfort with black athletes was the
condition apparently was that you not
murder your wife and her friend
that's the condition so he goes on he
talked about the famous car chase and
though in the white Bronco where AJ
Simpson was driving away from the
authorities and he writes quote the car
chase coming in the middle of the fifth
game of the NBA Finals cast a brief pall
on what had been a watershed moment for
black athletes to suggest that Simpson
overshadowed a decade's worth of good
will toward black athletes would be an
overstatement but Simpson arguably a
major source of this good will certainly
made clear the conditions that white
Americans put on their goodwill even as
the nation's greatest black athletes
continued to thrill and amaze the
conditions don't kill your wife he goes
on Knight quote in the 1960s the general
perception of black athletes had been
that they were too political too
political in the 1970s it was that they
were too selfish and flamboyant the
1980s though would prove to be a boon
for black athletes willing to cultivate
goodwill among white audiences this
growth was spurred by Michael Jordan as
the NBA fought to salvage is its
tarnished reputation it positioned
Jordan is a hard-working naturally
gifted and family-oriented athlete while
Nike and his other sponsors presented
him as a man actually capable of flying
so let's just assume the premise is true
that in the sixties a white America
viewed black athletes is too political
and in the 70s as too flamboyant and
selfish even is if this premise is true
certainly it's it makes sense that
people prefer hard-working
family-oriented athletes to showboaters
and anti-american political activists
who are protesting American
soldiers and American troops this isn't
a black or a white thing that's just an
American thing of course we would prefer
athletes who seem like good people and
who are well-adjusted and who were good
athletes to people who openly talk about
how they hate the country or Heather
showboating and selfish true across the
board not racial thing then he goes on
quote the means by which Simpson won
over America are antiquated especially
in an era in which black athletes such
as Colin Kaepernick and LeBron James not
only have embraced social justice but
also have convinced their leagues and
sponsors to do so as well the means by
which Simpson won over America is
antiquated no it's not this is the point
this is what Washington Post wants to
say they say yeah they turned on oj oj
thought he owed jay famously said they
asked him why he wasn't involved in more
racial and black causes he said I'm not
black I'm OJ it's a beautiful statement
he said I'm I'm an American I'm my own
man I'm not just going to be pigeonholed
into whatever a little racial group or
political group you want to put me I'm
bigger than that and what the Washington
Post wants to say is see and they turned
on OJ that's why the only way the only
way that black athletes can behave now
is by embracing radical leftist politics
like Colin Kaepernick it's the only way
no it isn't the only way you can be
hard-working you can be family-oriented
you can be pro America you can just
focus on athletes and not spite your
mouth out on on politics and America
will embrace you so long as you don't
murder your wife and her friend that's
the conclusion this is one of the
stupidest pieces I've seen in the
Washington Post in a long time which is
obviously saying quite a lot but that's
where we are a lot more to get to today
but unfortunately we don't have time so
we'll get to it tomorrow we'll get to
I'll tease it Alex Jones is now being
accused of having kiddie porn in emails
that he sent to the lawyers of Sandy
Hook victims parents can't make this
stuff up we will get to that story
tomorrow though in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles's the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show President Trump
promises to deport millions of illegal
immigrants that's today on the Ben
Shapiro show